lynne asked in a comment how do i run
globally scalable web apps on google
cloud with a minimum of maintenance
required
great question lynn i will base my
answer to your question on my personal
experience
some of my applications have served
hundreds of thousands of users per day
and like you i always want to minimize
maintenance so i will use serverless
tools only
[Music]
lynn mentioned scalable web apps there
are at least two ways to build those
some web apps compose custom html on the
server for each request
to serve more users you need to add more
server resources
this is a proven way of doing things
that works well
django laravel ruby on rails and other
backend frameworks to do this
we'll talk about how to use those
frameworks on google cloud in another
episode
in this episode we'll use the second
approach we'll skip server-side ranking
of html the logic for building the user
interface will run in the web browser
instead
i usually use the view framework for
this but you might use react angular
svelt or any other front-end framework
this video will show how to use any of
those frameworks with google cloud
this second approach scales well because
the server only needs to send static
files to users
and those static files can be served by
a content delivery network or cdn
which means even less load on your
server and even better scalability
now the web browser still needs to talk
to the server every now and then to read
data or to write data
the server exposes apis using rest or
graphql to make that happen
all right how would we host one of these
vue react angular or svelte web apps on
google cloud
and how would we do it in a low
maintenance serverless way
remember we have two components
static files and an api backed by
server-side code
there are three architectures that i've
personally used and that i really like i
will share them with you now i will also
share what i think are the pros and cons
of each one
and there will be a bonus tip for each
architecture then you can make up your
own mind about which one is right for
you
let's get started
architecture number one uses firebase
hosting for the static files firebase
functions for apis
and a database
i usually use firestore if i need a
non-relational database or cloud sql if
i need a relational database but there
are many other options
first bonus tip if you use firestore you
don't have to implement as many apis
yourself firestore has its own api that
web browsers can call
firestore can also push updates to
browsers when data changes in the
database
all right pros and cons
this architecture will scale well
globally
that's because firebase hosting has a
built-in cdn and the best part is you
don't have to configure it it just works
you will also deploy your static files
and your api with a single command
that means less risk of a half deployed
release
the drawback is that the api has to be
built in javascript or typescript
that's not been a problem for most of my
apps but many back-end developers prefer
python java go or something else
not to worry we have something for them
too
architecture number two uses firebase
hosting for the static files just like
before but cloud run for the apis
second bonus tip this and the previous
architecture will serve you static files
and new apis from different domains by
default to avoid having to deal with
cross origin resource sharing also known
as course you can configure firebase
hosting to put a single domain in front
of both your static files and your api
all right pros and cons
this architecture has the same cdn
advantage as the previous one but thanks
to cloud run you can implement your api
in any language
the main drawback in my experience is
that you will need to use two deployment
commands one to deploy your static files
and another to deploy your api
if one deployment fails maybe because of
a bug in your code and the other
succeeds your app could end up in a bad
state
architecture number three uses cloudrun
both for hosting the static files and
for the api
third bonus tip if you like docker
containers this is the architecture for
you
pros and cons
with this architecture you get a single
deployment command i like that
also your entire application will be
packaged up in a docker container that's
easy to test and to move around between
environments
but you don't get the nice built-in cdn
with this approach
that's okay if your users are based in
one country or in a few neighboring
countries
just deploy your app in a google data
center close to them
also it won't matter if you prefer to
set up and fine-tune the cdn yourself
well there you have it
weigh the pros and cons of each
architecture and see which one is right
for you
what is your favorite way of hosting web
applications on google cloud is it one
of these three or something completely
different
or perhaps you have questions about this
episode
either way let me know in the comments
thanks for joining me and see you next
time
[Music]